on june 13 2018 we released a video
called tactical reloads
this action short took the idea of two
cops that just took the world
of tactical pistol maneuvers way too
seriously to the point where they had to
show off with every single move
because it's more important to be cool
than it was to stop crime we took that a
step further with
tack two cool reloads jumping more into
the story of these characters than most
people thought would be smart to do
however we didn't take it far enough so
this week we are headed to san antonio
texas to jump into production of the
third
most ambitious installment of the
tactical reload series
tacticool three loads
so this time the cast is bigger the
reloads are even more insane and
complicated to shoot and the pressure is
even higher because if this works out it
will prove to me that tacticool reloads
has legs beyond just a few shorts on
youtube
that we can actually take this concept
and make it into a full episodic show
but there's a ton that needs to happen
between now and then
what are you so happy about we're
shooting tactical three loads right now
with freddie wong
and matt best hey matt best what are we
doing today
i am a uh sweet gun nerd that's uh
luckily hanging out with these two
awesome fbi what are you doing for the
video
i'm gonna mess up on my lines i'm method
acting as a character
i'm a newbie on the team freddie and you
know nico are gonna show me how to get
it done
the hell is that 60 round drum
we are filming the action scenes for
this piece at the black rifle coffee
headquarters in
their warehouse now we have a ton to get
through we don't have
a lot of time but with these three guys
together on camera i think
magic is going to happen what's our boy
band name
uh the calibers the cat oh i see what
you did there i'm 9 mil
this is 556 and of course 762.
hello i'm a pistol 762. i mean you could
technically have an ar
pistol or kyle bird in 762. but the
platform depicts whether or not it's a
rifle or pistol see this is why i just
joined the band
all right so this wouldn't be tactical
three loads if it didn't have some sweet
reloads right
we only have two days to film this whole
thing
it's very ambitious there's a lot to do
the only way we can actually
make both of our days is to previz the
reload sequences
nico took what was in his brain and he
shot a previz
with wes and with sam you know kind of
choreographed the reload sequences i
think there's like four of them so that
when we get the set we know exactly what
we need to knock out and we're not
thinking oh
what do we do is already thought about
beforehand you you got to pre-think it
basically we're our same lighting setup
cool i'm gonna grab the cheap mags
it allows us to just knock out beat
after beat after beat and move on so we
can make our day
rolling action action
[Music]
not bad that was that was it though that
was the move ready one more yeah
rolling again action
action towards me a little bit you can
just look at each other no oh yep the
performance
was not right i don't even have to say
it nico just knows oh i gotta get this
so we
developed a really nice rhythm action
[Music]
from move on
oh great that's great nailed it great
can't even see it it's magic i can see
it perfectly on camera
i can hold it looser
three two one action
cool i'm right-handed though so is it
gonna be like like this
like that yeah damn it sorry just
okay can you put your finger oh
the bullet knows what to go there
oh you know what that's so much more
comfortable you feel the stability
though yeah like it's not even moving
it's like a rock
yeah dad yeah heather look mean
[Music]
dad dad that's great
daddy help me daddy
directing child actors it's challenging
because you need to know your scene
inside and out because all you can do is
get building blocks there's no coverage
there's no running the entire scene
let's get a line give a line get a line
give a line
little by little go for it heather
yeah let's do it one more time charlotte
can you look scared for me when you get
spin around
you're like yeah that's great all right
let's do it
dad daddy but charles is doing great
like
she's delivering the lines really well
she actually has the correct eye line
which i wasn't expecting
three two one daddy helps me
she's actually like i'm talk giving her
direction but then she looks at matt and
gives the lines i'm like all right this
is great
yeah charlotte that was awesome good
work charlotte's wrath
charlie good work thank you so much
there's a thing with kid actors they're
just they get distracted easily they're
terrible
at the end of the day you never want to
use one of these it's just a lot of work
right see
super easy to work with i'll figure it
out
sideways somersault
boom done beautiful
that was actually perfect you guys just
totally nailed it on the first try cut
bang you have to push it comes out
faster
action awesome i think that might have
been it
tactical reloads are done
[Applause]
we're almost done jake yeah we still
have a hole with that john wick sequence
we have basically have the intro of john
wick to film
and then we're done it's another day at
the goon factory
do not trip on diesel open up my
retirements from lagoon benefits
and action
so we wrapped up our shoot here in texas
it's time to go back to the studio
and start post-production on this beast
so when we're editing this thing
there's a number of people going through
so i think i started the edit i set it
up got some notes from nico
then we passed it to matt matt finished
it and then that went to sam
and sam really went in and started doing
the micro chopping and everything and
sam was the one who realized
hey we need we need some pickups here
mutiny
are we talking mutiny what do you want
to know so this video is
nico's baby here's the problem he's
going out of town for like two weeks
and the video is basically well it's not
done
there's like dozens of insert shots that
haven't been filmed
the edit's not locked mind you he's
gonna be in the boundary waters in
northern minnesota where there's no
service
i'm just looking at the video going all
right if we're gonna get this done i'm
gonna have to
take this over since there's a ton of
insert shots that are like really
crucial like
all of the shots where the guns are
doing tricks like
literally none of those shots have been
filmed except for like one small
sequence
so it's gonna be up to me to figure out
what those are gonna look like
and so far after going through the edit
i feel like the video needs
one more spectacle at the end of the day
what you guys want is a friend
or a coworker that can sit down and give
you honest
feedback what do they think as a random
person viewing it for the first time
if they're feeling something guaranteed
a thousand other people are gonna feel
that
same thing here's my true my one true
personal gripe are you ready
nobody says
reloading in the entire video how do you
make a tactical real i don't know what
maybe they're like occupied with
something else
but they forgot to say reloading what
i'm i'm literally i'm going to
pull nico aside one second i'm going to
say nico put on this jacket put on this
headband
just yell reloading at me really quick
because we need to put this in the video
i want to make sure that
we can show some sort of like
consistency you know through these
episodes like making sure we can we can
nail the feel of this show because
as you may know on our website there is
a tactical
reloads exclusive show that we are
pitching to you guys and we would love
to make more of it the only way i feel
like we can convince anyone to make it
is that we can demonstrate that we
really have a good grasp on what we're
doing over here
[Music]
freddy's here to watch the cut of
tactical throughout
at this point freddy's been like the
best friend in the world i mean he came
out to texas to film with us
he needs to like this video if not then
it shows that the second one having a
story was just a fluke if this video is
good
not only does it show there's potential
for the series to keep going hopefully
it brings freddie in and gets them
passionately engaged for making this
series with us
and hopefully it gets all of you
watching passionately engaged
to watch more if we can get five
gut busting freddy laughs then i think
this video is a success
anything below that i'll also be
counting
pity laughs yeah pity laughs will
actually be tracked
i imagine at least one out of him
and maybe one i'm really happy with this
piece
i think it's turned out really well i
think pretty's gonna like it a lot i'm
just looking for ah
here's how you know if i don't like
something by the way the secret to
freddie not liking something
is if afterwards i ask you a technical
question
you try and steer it in a different
direction how'd you guys do that one
that means i didn't like it you don't
want to say anything bad but you also
don't want to like we want to engage
because obviously everything has
something that's worth learning from
everything everything has something
that's like cool or interesting about it
definitely
definitely all right let's play it
focus try not to think about jessica
[Laughter]
i don't know
that's really good
[Laughter]
the hell is that 60 round drum never
have to reload
[Laughter]
tango
[Laughter]
friends
all right man so the so the fourth one
it's gotta start with me sucking down
penis right right oh my god on the hot
sunny beaches
you know it's like it's like it's like
so
it's many 50 empty ones and then it's
just like you just like oh
i'm trying to finish like this like oh
god
she's in the process of leaving you yeah
like 100
i was more concerned with the [ __ ]
down penis part
i'm gone like this is disgusting
[Laughter]
so when's the fourth one happening then
well i mean it really depends on if
people green light the series on the
website
our fate is in the hand of internet
strangers
let's do it i'm waiting i'm ready to go
did you count the number of gut left
yeah i mean i lost count at like seven i
think that far exceeded
our expectations i was looking for five
to me that just no
yeah we can do more of this well that
about wraps it up over here on the
corridor crew channel but if you have
not seen tactical three loads yet
head on over to the corridor youtube
channel if you're a member of our site
then obviously you can watch them over
on corridordigital.com that's also an
option
and once again huge thank you to
everybody over at black rifle coffee
even if you're just a casual coffee
drinker they've got something for
everybody they've got a coffee club
subscription they've got a ready to
drink coffee that comes in a can in case
you like to drink one on your way to
work every morning or whatnot and
they've also got an exclusive coffee
subscription that delivers
select roasts that are different every
month if you're a coffee connoisseur
if you'd like to see more tactical
reloads videos we want to make a show
out of this on the website so consider
quarterdigital.com consider a membership
if you can spare 399 a month it's it's a
really cool thing we're doing over there
all right see you later